Hello 大家好，欢迎收听古典布丹调的第三期节目，没错，今天又是一期歌单分享。
这期歌单没有一个非常明确的音乐上的主题，但是有情绪上的主题，都是Allegro快版乐章。
音乐整体上比较激烈，旋律感也很强，相信大家刚刚已经从片头海顿的这首弦四中感受到了一二。
那么今天跟大家分享的无首作品，都是从我自己的通情歌单里面跳出来的。
从海顿、贝多芬、肖撒克威奇、歌士文，还有一首来自南美的阿根廷音乐。
风格可以说是非常的齐全，而且时间跨度也很大。
可能上一首还在古典的平衡中徘徊，下一首就给你干到了二十世纪。
那么今天除了分享美好的音乐之外呢，也想跟大家穿插聊聊我与这些音乐的小故事。
比如我第一次听是在什么时候，我平时发现新的音乐会有哪些途径等等这些小话题。
OK，那我们话不多说，直接从第一首海顿开始。
作曲家海顿我觉得古典乐迷、非古典乐迷应该都非常熟悉。
不知道大家第一首听的海顿的作品是什么，或者对海顿有哪些刻板印象。
比如音乐史的官方抬头，交响乐之父，弦乐四重奏之父，
穿着宫廷之父的老好人，或者偏感性一点的，
他的音乐很有安全感，像一位四平八稳的德高望中的长者。
但我觉得今天这首齐事可能会给大家带来一些不一样的感觉。
它是海顿弦乐四重奏中少有的，充满攻击性和画面感的作品。
尤其是在第四月长那个开头的主题，连续的后半拍组成的乐句，
大家是否能感受到那种酷似马蹄的节奏型。
这首弦四是海顿的晚期代表作之一。
那会儿海顿刚结束他的第二次伦敦旅行，
被英国的音乐听规模和观众的热情所震撼。
所以他的晚期作品，尤其是作品号74这组作品，
开始追求更宏大的音响和更鲜明的戏剧对比。
我们来前后对比听一下行程鲜明性格反差的开头段和中段。
OK，现在进入中段了。
但是骑士这个作品并不是海顿给起的，
而是后人因为酷似马蹄奔跑的节奏型，
给他取得这个充满画面感的绰好。
其实大家听十八世纪古典时期音乐作品的时候，
也可以借助这种巨像的想象力，尤其是海顿和莫加特。
我们可以去想象一些非常巨像的事物或者情感。
因为在这个时期，绝大部分音乐所表达的情感，
是相对而言比较类型化的。
比如海顿写一段音乐，
他不会把私人的情感经历放入音乐中，
更可能会写那种带有社会共识的场景，
比如一个优雅的贵族在舞会中略带优伤的夺布，
又比如他一个奥地地人去伦敦后的建文，
这种非常课题化的场景。
导致这种音乐表达的原因有二，
第一，受环境决定的，
海顿的大部分时间都待在艾斯特哈奇亲王的宫廷里，
他的音乐是服务于亲王的日常娱乐或者仪式的，
因为当时还不是一个鼓励作曲家大声喊我的时代。
直到浪漫主义时期的舒伯特，
他是被称为西方音乐史上第一位自由艺术家。
第二，时代的审美趋势决定的，
古典主义追求的是形式的美，
比例的均衡，逻辑的清晰。
我们听海顿的绝大部分作品，
都逃不出那个时代的节奏和分上。
比如在这首骑士里，那种属于十八世纪末的，
充满火力的骄傲的骑士精神，
就是海顿想表达的某种审美趋势。
这首贤词是我听过的次数最多的海顿的作品，
但并不是完全因为我的审美喜好，
而是来自我的一段求学经历。
我在大学时期，除了主专业是西方乐史，
在本科大三的时候，
我还考了本校的管弦系的中纪性专业，
是的，我从小是学弦乐的。
那么我的听众里，如果有管弦系的同学，
肯定知道，所有音乐学院里面都有一门必修课，
就是十多月演奏，
你需要自己去找重奏伙伴，
然后组成这个重奏。
那么我们学校的十多月教学曲目选择，
其实就是按照这个古典浪漫，印象派，
不怎么会拉而逝计，
这样一个顺序去教学和演奏的。
按照顺序来讲，就是海顿，
摩扎特，贝多芬，之后就是舒伯特，
博拉姆斯，也会拉一些民族乐派的，
比如说斯玫塔纳，德沃夏克，
再难一点的话，比如说德彪西和拉威尔，
当然新伯格他也有这种审议，
但是我们的老师都不太喜欢这种当代作品，
反而越往后的作品就越虐中题，
比如博拉姆斯第二弦四中奏的中题，
斯玫塔纳我的祖国里面也有一段比较难的中题的段落。
所以海顿在弦四里面肯定不算难的，
但为什么我觉得这种作品有一种情有独钟的感觉呢？
首先肯定是因为它是我拉的第一手弦四，
或者说专业学习的第一手弦四，
不管是对演奏弦四的感受，
还是你和重奏组的四位同学从不认识，
到渐渐熟悉的过程都是非常难忘的，
算是一种新兵弹子的新鲜感。
我们当然也听了非常多的版本，
比如说艾莫森、阿班贝尔格、哈根，
然后我们也会去模仿一些不同组合的速度，
他们的风格，这些体验都是全新的。
OK，下面的选项时间，
给大家推荐的版本是来自奥地利的弦松奏，
哈尔根重奏组演奏的骑士。
刚才我们听了18世纪海顿笔下的骑士，
接下来就是我将一脚油门踩到20世纪，
让我们有请肖洒科威奇和他的双钢琴小鞋奏曲。
肖洒科威奇最令人熟知的作品可能是他的第二原舞曲，
但这并不意味着他是走向大众风格的作曲家。
小鞋奏曲《Country Tino》是个相当小众的题材，
它不像正常的鞋奏曲那样有三四个乐章，
每个乐章会分快板、慢板、鞋血曲，
也有关心日子的注正。
小鞋奏曲它更短小、精致，
通常是单乐章的结构，
但内部也会有不同速度的变化和对比。
双钢琴小鞋奏曲则意味着没有乐队、没有指挥，
只有两架钢琴，两位演奏者。
他们既是独奏家，又是彼此的伴奏，甚至是彼此的对手。
有一些评论形容之后曲的像一场父子之间的对话，
事实上这首曲的确实是老肖写给他的儿子马克西姆肖洒科威奇的。
当时的马克西姆只有15岁，
正在莫斯科音乐学院学钢琴。
老肖写完之后曲的之后，
由马克西姆和他的同学完成了首演。
想象一下这种反差，一位在苏联高压政治下活下来的，
写过那些沉重交响曲的作曲下，
同时又是一位父亲。
写给自己15岁的儿子竟然是这样一首相对来说比较轻松活泼的曲子。
但这恰恰反映了一位作曲家的多面性。
这里有一个特别肖洒科威奇的处理。
老肖喜欢用一种叫肖洒科威奇八度的手法，
就是把同一个旋律隔开一个，甚至几个八度同时弹。
听起来像是音区的扩张，
两架钢琴通过这种方式模拟出了交场乐队的效果，
明明是两架钢琴却有一种千军万马般的气势。
所以这首作品就是为了音乐会而生的，
很有舞台效果，非常适合现场去联听。
给大家推演版本是阿格里奇和莉莉亚斯·尾巴斯坦对黄金搭档。
在2006年卢加诺音乐节的现场。
这个版本是有录音的，
但是在YouTube上面好像找不到视频。
我看了一下阿格里奇最近演奏这个作品是在去年瑞士维尔比耶音乐节。
我把视频的地址放在Show Notes里面了，
大家感兴趣的话可以去看一下这个作品的现场。
阿格里奇那种灵力的触见，
音色穿透力极强，
却依然保持着琴弦充分震动后的余音。
OK，现在是纯响时间，
我们再来感受一下乐曲中激情澎湃的段落，
阿格里奇和Zeeberstein形成风暴般的一段对话。
接下来这首对我来说特别私人，
先交代一下背景，
这首曲的中文名叫《人群》，
是法国相松的一首经典作品，
有爱里特皮压夫唱红的，
对，就是那位唱玫瑰人生的歌手。
原版是那种老巴黎的味道，
首分琴、咖啡馆，
人群拥挤的街头，
一个男人和一个女人在人群中相遇、
相爱又被冲散。
但我今天给大家推荐的版本是大提琴改编版，
我觉得更符合二世纪的音乐审美。
大提琴这些乐器比人声更接近人群本身，
那种人群的孤独感，
被琴弦摩擦出了另一种质感。
刚给大家播放的版本来自法国大提琴家。
卡普松2023年的专辑《目的地巴黎》。
这张专辑本身就是一份写给巴黎的情书，
皮压夫的Bioxy Lavergno全是法国作曲家的声音。
除了我自己学习的乐器之外，
我最喜欢的就是大提琴，
我手头有好几张反复听的大提琴作品，
比如米沙迈基斯的洛克克编奏曲，
罗斯特罗伯维起的大提琴舞伴奏，
马佑有的作品籍《Impressions》印象级。
这是一张跨界作品，
从巴和皮压遭辣，
到莫里康内谈顿，
可以说是马佑有30年音乐生涯的一部自传。
另外我也非常喜欢王健的Reverie，
《梦幻曲级》，
是他与其他演奏家戈兰索契尔的跨界合作。
那么卡普松2023年的专辑《目的地》
也是一张跨界专辑。
音乐小品，
情歌剧上松，
音乐剧，
电影配乐。
作曲家则是从巴洛克的拉默。
到拉曼主义时期的比采古诺，
再到印象派的德彪希拉威尔，
然后是皮压服务，
再到当代音乐作品。
对我自己来说，
选一些喜欢的演奏家的专辑，
并且整张整张的去听，
是我一直以来的一种习惯，
也是我希望自己不要迷失在算法里吧。
从专辑的风格和选曲，
可以尽可能的了解。
一位演奏家的审美喜好，
主动走进一位艺术家的内心地图，
你也许还会找到一些。
舒适区以外的作品，
被那些非主打的作品击中。
比如这首《人群》，
皮压服的原唱版本是。
《人群推散着我们》，
我迷失在你的眼中，
巴黎在歌唱，
而大地型的版本
把这个故事变成了一个人的回忆，
而不是两个人的相拥，
是一个人站在多年后的街头，
突然想起了那个人。
不知道大家有没有注意到，
这个版本的处理
有一个很特别的空间感，
大地型的声音
好像是从远处传来的，
混乡很大，
好像是在巴黎某个古老的教堂里录的。
下面这首作品可以算是。
我的钢琴启门吧。
来，我们一起来听。
贝多芬的《热情》，
第三乐章。
《热情》悲创月光。
被公认为是
贝多芬中期的
三大钢琴作名曲。
《热情》写于
1804-1806年之间,。
那是贝多芬的什么时期呢？
她的耳朵已经几乎笼了。
她在1802年写下。
《海力更是雅特遗竹》，
想过自杀，
但挺过来了。
然后她写下了《英雄交响》曲，
写下了《拉族摩夫斯基》
《贤约四重奏》，
也写下了这首《热情》。
这是一种什么状态，
不是绝望，也不是任命，
而是一种像命运宣战的姿态。
《贤约》上之后，
曲的有几个特点，
第一乐章开头的那个。
三音动机，
是整个乐章的种子，
不断变形，不断强化。
到了第三乐章，
才是真正的暴风雨。
右手是急速的阴流，
左手是和弦的冲击，
像一场剧风从地平线卷过来。
这种极端的对比
是贝多芬中期的标志。
她不是写优美的旋律，
而是写戏剧的冲突。
ok，下面是纯响时间，
我们再来感受一下。
贝多芬的热情。
最后一首作品，
我们将从贝多芬的。
暴风雨里走出来，
再次走进巴黎的阳光。
有请这首歌手的
一个美国人在巴黎。
这首一个美国人在巴黎，
写于1928年，
那会儿一战结束，
二战还没有来，
中间的这十年，
叫做《咆哮的二十年代》。
美国经济繁荣，
绝世乐，
席卷全球，
非子杰拉德在写
了不起的盖茨比。
美国作家海明威的。
在我们的时代里，
太阳照常升起，
两本著作在巴黎出版。
歌手的年纪也来到了巴黎，
这首曲子虽然是
管弦乐编织，
但严格来说，
不是交响曲，
也不是写奏曲。
歌手自己叫他狂响曲，
曲子分两个部分，
第一部分是美国游客。
在巴黎街头闲逛，
东张西望，
看什么都是新鲜的。
第二部分是他写想家了，
然后在意向遇到的同胞，
心情一下子又好起来了。
他最大的特色就是交响爵士话，
歌手们把
蓝调音阶，爵士和声，
格拉泰姆节奏，
全都塞进了交响乐队里，
大家听那些旋律，
一听就是美国的，
但那些街头的噪音，
出车的喇叭声，
又是巴黎的。
说回到历史背景，
为什么1920年代。
会有这种
美国人在巴黎的作品？
当然有战争的关系，
一战之后，
欧洲元旗大商，
美国后来居上，
而且二战还没有爆发的时候，
有很多欧洲的作曲家，
艺术家往美国跑，
比如斯拉文斯基，
来和马尼诺夫，
都去了美国。
但歌手们想反，
他往欧洲跑，
他想在巴黎找到些什么呢？
可能是那种欧洲的文化积电，
那种历史的厚重感，
那是纽约还没有的东西。
这首曲子最后，
有一段Bloose风格的旋律，
非常动人，
那是歌手们这个，
美国游客在巴黎，
突然有点想家了。
歌手们让Sax 吹出那个旋律，
拥拦，忧郁，
带着一点爵士的Bluenote，
但最后，
查尔斯顿舞曲的节奏又回来了，
他又回到了人群中，
回到了快乐里。
下面是纯想时间，
一起来感受一下，
美国人在巴黎的时光。
以上就是本期播客要分享的。
无首作品。
不管你是不是在通情，
都希望这些曲子能带给你欢乐。
我们下期播客再见，
拜拜!